foreign
so today's question comes from Clayton
in Texas I'd like to move it to a nicer
neighborhood however with the housing
prices High and the interest rates High
I'm not sure it's the best time the only
debt I have is my house 145 000 left on
my loan at
2.65 rate I'm confident I can sell my
house for three hundred thousand dollars
if not more the downfall is I'm giving
up a low interest rate for a more
expensive house and a higher rate thank
you for your time
yeah I mean this is a this is a very
standard question a lot of people are
asking like hey I want to upgrade but
then as they do the math and they look
at the interest rate and over the life
of a loan you know we say paid off
faster than 15 years but a 15-year loan
I mean you're going to be paying a
substantial more money towards your
interest and so for a lot of people it's
making them hesitant but you guys I mean
My My Philosophy always with buying a
home is buy it when you're ready it's a
great investment we want everyone to own
a home we want you to have a primary
residence when you're ready it's a great
part of your financial picture and so
you know you have to really be able to
kind of take the noise and everything
going on that you hear at the news and
everything and and kind of mute all of
that and say okay where are we
financially and as long as your payment
is within that 25 of your take-home pay
uh you're on a 15-year fixed rate and
and if all of that math still works for
you and you have a good down payment
then you can move forward with it but
you have to know mathematically yeah
we're going to be paying more in
interest but I mean David that's what I
mean a lot of people are they're they're
pausing a home buying because like gosh
I have a good right now in my current
home
and if we move it's it's going to Triple
basically into a higher interest rate
well as long as you're at 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fix there's
two things going on when you do that one
is uh you're going to get out of debt
faster than 15 years
okay two is we know you can afford it
yeah that you're buying a house that is
reasonable your move up is reasonable if
it fits those two things Clayton you
should go ahead and do it now
okay because here here's the thing you
you said some incorrect things here okay
however with housing prices being high
no honey housing prices just are
they're not high they're high compared
to yesterday they're low compared to
tomorrow
they're not coming back down when you
say they're high it's almost as if you
think they might come back down they're
not coming down
okay in 60 years 70 years house prices
have gone down one time temporarily in
2008 and they shot back up
one time if you're gonna sit around and
wait on one time in 60 or 70 years to
happen you're never getting a house
they're not coming down
you're buying a house the way it is now
and when you're ready that's right as
far as the interest rates go I don't
know if they'll come back down if they
do refinance
if they don't pay off the stupid loan
because you know what my interest rate
is on my loan zero because I don't have
a loan
so there's a good way to get a zero
percent pay the stinking thing off pay
it off and then you don't worry about
the interest rates you're not keeping
this thing around like as a pet you're
getting rid of the mortgage so you you
know number one house prices are not
coming back down if you're going to buy
this is best time to buy
in the next 20 years right now price
wise
uh if interest rates are oh I'm worried
about interest rates interest rates are
not high
they're not high historically they are
higher than that 0.65 right they're
higher than they were but over the
course of history right they're really
not high
and so if they did come back down then
just refinance when you were selling
houses in the 80s now Selling Houses in
the 80s or 17 15 yeah yeah okay and they
came down to 14 and people came out of
their houses like they did after covid
trying you couldn't they're stampeding
to buy houses and rates were 14. and
then they went down to 10 and then they
went down to nine and somebody called me
up and said I don't want to buy a house
at nine I was on the radio then and I'm
like why it's nine as compared to 17 I
thought it was awesome yeah and I said
you'll never see six and little did I
know how dumb I was of course you saw
six on the way down to three but yeah
but the the three percent two percent
interest rate range was artificially
created by the government trying to
recover from 2008. the market did not
drive us down there the market has
hovered around six for decades a couple
of decades now
in and out of the six percent range so
historically it's only compared to a
year ago or two years ago that they're
high so this is the time to buy a house
it is the time for sure to sell a house
yeah there's still more buyers than
there are houses yep still a seller's
market so get with a good real estate
agent go to ramseysolutions.com
click on uh ELP for Ramsey trusted
endorsed local provider for real estate
agent that knows what the flip they're
doing
that has experience that sells a bunch
of houses and if you're ready to move
you're out of debt you're buying it 25
of your take-home pay Rachel's exactly
right it's not based on all the noise
that you're hearing from your friends or
in the marketplace it's when you're
ready it's like I was with this wine
expert the other day who's one of the
most renowned Wine Guys in the world and
um he said I said what is that good wine
and he said do you like it
that's the definition of good wine
do you like it when you are ready you
know and so you know do you like it are
you ready are you in good shape are you
ready to make the move